while house republicans are holding
public hearings this afternoon on the
origins of kova
they want to know whether the virus
leaked from a lab in wuhan china
republicans have been calling on speaker
nancy pelosi to conduct hearings so far
she has refused former top state
department investigator david asher
is among those set to testify today he
joins us now dr asher
it's always great to have you on i want
to put up on the screen here you'll be
testifying today along with admiral
brett jawah dr richard muller and dr
stephen quay
dr asher in this forum with lawmakers
what's your focus what do you want the
direction
of this forum to be well i really want
to focus on the malevolent designs and
capabilities of the chinese communist
government has developed around biology
synthetic biology
in the future warfare and i'm not saying
that this was released as a
attack vector using biology but they
were certainly developing it uh secretly
at the wuhan institute of virology and
it apparently got loose through some
accident
that has had colossal implications for
global state society and economy
and we've got to hold the chinese
accountable that's the focus
it's not a partisan issue everybody
should agree with this we we hear a lot
that we have to hold the chinese
accountable and the gop lawmakers are
saying the same thing they're talking
about possibility of sanctions and visa
restrictions
even relocating the olympics is this
enough
in your estimation to compel the chinese
to cooperate
probably not enough uh we may never be
able to compel them to cooperate but
we may be able to coerce them uh it's a
little different different than being a
nice diplomat like
i was trained to be we could be a lot
more coercive sanctions could be
more draconian nature if they don't
comply with let's say six months
to come forward with evidence we also
could unleash the great american
ambulance chasing attorneys and lawyers
who could uh
make uh the the uh civil litigation
claims against the chinese on behalf of
all these victims we've lost
uh you know 600 000 people we've ruined
the lives of millions
and we've set back our economy nearly 20
of gdp yeah
i mean this is not in this is the worst
thing since the great depression
and world war ii in some ways combined
economically
it's a fair point you know there's
there's been a lot of talk about
consequences and so far we have seen
china really experience very few
consequences steve scalise tweeted the
following quoting here
never forget what happened when
republicans rightly said kovit likely
came
from the wuhan lab the media called us
conspiracy theorists
big tech censored us the dem controlled
coronavirus committee
refused and still refuses to hold a
hearing on it time for accountability
again the word accountability
the problem here is he's right in one
capacity we certainly did lose a great
deal of time
because of those delays yeah but i'm not
going to blame the democratic party uh
on this one we've had excellent meetings
so far here in washington with
democratic staffers and
members at least by remote i just think
they don't want to be in the same room
with republicans on this thing and
maybe vice versa so i can't fix the
partisanship in this town
but we can fix what the communist
chinese did
to try to undermine our country and the
world
system with kovid even if they didn't do
it deliberately
they knew it would spread they let it
spread and it cost us millions of lives
and
and
that we have to bring these people to
heal over in communist china if not the
democrats what about
the media what about those in big tech
that censored this story saying this was
nothing but a conspiracy
well they were wrong from the beginning
they they're going to be proven wrong
and
wrong and wronger if there's such a
phrase uh i mean it's it's the evidence
the scientific evidence that
dr quay and dr boehler are presenting
are literally undisputed facts the
question is how did they get there
and i'll let them talk on your show some
other time but it's very powerful data
analysis
the sequence itself tells you something
despite what all these scientists have
said and i i've heard that from
many famous scientists but none of them
want to go on the record because they're
afraid the chinese will cut them off
from funding
and so will nih yup dr asher we will be
watching the forum today thank you for
coming on sir
thank you very much